[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez déjà vécu une très
grande frustration en tant que client
le genre de frustration qui vous fout la
rage qui vous donne envie de tout casser
une banque
ou bien avec votre opérateur
et moi en 2019 j'ai vécu ce genre de
frustration
9000 francs c'est la somme que j'avais
sur mon compte bancaire à l'époque
on traverse tous ces moments de galère
n'est-ce pas
mais le problème c'est que on se
trouvait
au milieu du mois
comment est-ce que je vais finir le mois
avec 900 Mission Impossible n'est-ce pas
et donc je me dis quoi ok il faut que je
trouve une solution
et dès que je dois me tourner
ma banque
pourquoi parce que c'est eux ce sont eux
qui ressemblent mon salaire n'est-ce pas
et quand nous sommes mon salaire
et donc je vais à l'agence de la banque
j'attends une heure dehors à la période
de la banque
vous connaissez
pas grave
à l'intérieur je vais voir ma
gestionnaire et j'attends encore une
heure avant de pouvoir la voir
et je finir par voir la gestionnaire je
viens de voir elle où on peut
l'exprimer
parce que ça va pas je vais pas finir le
mois j'ai besoin de quelque chose une
rallonge justement une avance sur
salaire un près d'urgence quelque chose
parce que ce sera trop difficile
et la dame elle est là elle est assise
que je suis rentré elle n'a jamais
regardé
monsieur il y a pas de problème ce qu'on
va faire c'est que vous allez remplir ce
document vous allez faire une lettre
manuscrite la fameuse lettre manuscrite
voilà et puis remettre dans le processus
on va voir ce que ça donne OK
moi je suis en face de la fixe en
espérant que elle m'accorde un peu de
dignité qu'elle me regarde en fait elle
me regarde pas et je lui dis madame ok
il y a pas de problème est-ce que vous
savez combien de temps ce processus va
prendre elle me dit je sais pas combien
de temps ça va prendre on va voir on va
faire on va voir OK
madame excusez-moi mais j'ai vu que vous
avez lancé un nouveau service qui est
assez innovant qui permet de transférer
l'argent entre son compte et son compte
bancaire et son compte globalement
est-ce que vous pouvez m'inscrire ça
parce que j'ai même plus fort sur mon
compte je peux pas retirer au guichet
je viens de passer deux heures
dans la banque et je suis au point zéro
mon problème n'a pas été résolu
et à ce moment-là je sens je sens ça
monter la frustration
je me sens face au système je me sens
comme David congolia sauf que j'ai pas
la prendre
je pars quelques mois plus tard
je rencontre un ami
s'appelle
et on prend un café
de ses mémoires avec lui ça bon je
n'arrivais pas à ouvrir un compte qui
venait de rentrer au pays
on discute on discute et il me parle
de ceux de son idée de ce concept qui
consiste à utiliser la technologie ou
offrir de meilleurs services financiers
c'est pas mon truc
mais je me suis souvenu de la boule de
la frustration il y a quelques mois
et en fait quand je te demande cette
gestionnaire tout ce que je voulais
c'est d'avoir une baguette magique
quel est maintenant le pouvoir de
racheter la banque de la renvoyer
de renvoyer son patron et de renvoyer le
patron de son patron
et tout ça c'est revenu je dis non tu
sais quoi ça
c'est le destin je sais pas mais cette
idée je veux passer lundi prochain les
années de ma vie à travailler dessus
c'est trop important
mais vouloir c'est différent de pouvoir
n'est-ce pas comment est-ce que on
change les services financiers on fait
quoi on crée une banque
je sais pas on n'avait pas l'argent de
créer la banque on avait même pas les
ressources pour créer la banque et même
si on se débrouillait pour créer cette
banque elle allaite forcément comme les
banques convoyeurs
on nous a fait un concept qui s'appelle
l'océan rouge
alors pour mieux vous illustrer supposer
que vous êtes un pécheur d'accord
que vous avez la pêche dans le sang les
amis péchés quand vous partez sur cours
d'eau vous savez où repérer les
meilleurs poissons
vous savez comment pêcher les poissons
de meilleur qualité mais ça mais comment
préparer le poisson
l'offrir à vos clients
et vous arrivez sur une ville
sur la côte et vous voulez vous
installer et faire prospérer votre
activité de pêcheur et vous vous rendez
compte en fait que en fait dans cette
ville on pêche différemment
et que vous moi concept de pêche de
bactrice ça peut pas marcher là-bas
pourquoi parce que les pêcheurs là-bas
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont ils ont des
chalutiers
nous avons notre petite canne à pêche
avec vos théories là-bas ils ont des
vrais bâtons industriels
le fond de la mer ils s'en foutent de la
qualité du poisson ils prennent tout on
s'en fout de la qualité on va vendre au
client
et s'inscrit créer l'océan rouge la
compétition intense sur un petit marché
et vous en tant que pêcheur avec amour
pour la pêche est-ce que vous pouvez
lutter contre ces jeunes
est-ce que vous pouvez pas parce que
vous n'avez pas les moyens et en général
il faut énormément de moyens pour
pénétrer ce genre d'écosystème et ce
genre de cause du système sont régulés
et sont gardés par un arbitre qui
s'assume que
les nouveaux venus ont des problèmes
pour rentrer
et c'est pas ça cette écosystème qu'on
était
et on peut se dire que
en fait cette compétition
intense dans l'océan rouge c'est bon
pour le client c'est ce qu'on peut
penser mais en vrai quand vous regardez
de proche de
ça conduit une situation de monopole et
ça conduit un écosystème de léthargie
parce que personne n'a envie de prendre
des risques tout le monde est allé
et comme vous gardez nos proches de près
pardon il y a très peu de valeur créée
pour le client le client n'existe pas la
zéro en partie pour le client dans ce
genre d'écosystème
de quoi on parle on parle de marge on
parle de bénéfice on parle d'éducateur
de performance le client n'existe pas
et la théorie dit aussi que en fait dans
ce genre de système
il y a une façon de voir les choses
c'est d'aller vers l'océan bleu
ce que vous comprenez vous sortez de
l'océan rouge que vous allez vers
l'océan bleu ou définissez votre nouveau
marché vous créez quelque chose de
nouveau parce que vous ne pouvez pas
lutter contre les gens qui sont dans le
cerveau
absolument à rien et donc on a notre
premier nos stratégie on va créer notre
marché on va créer quelque chose d'autre
le X c'est quoi
c'est que dans la zone euro
tous ceux qui veulent créer des services
financiers
quel que soit l'innovation qui est
derrière
et bien ils doivent composer avec les
banques
pourquoi c'est fait à dessin pour
protéger la population parce que si tout
le monde se lève et commence à créer des
applications chacun fait ce qu'il veut
on aura des problèmes et donc aussi il
nous vend que votre projet soit vous
devez composer avec la banque et ça
c'est le premier problème comment
trouver une banque avec qui on va
coopérer et donc on s'est mis à demander
des rendez-vous
[Musique]
rencontre tu rencontres on explique le
projet c'est toujours la même chose ah
ok écoutez bon on va vous rappeler mais
bien sûr rappelez pas et vous savez quoi
il rappelait pas parce que le projet
qu'on proposait le rentrer pas dans leur
moule
c'était pas la même chose donc il faut
pas qu'on se voit qu'on puisse créer ça
et donc on a passé des mois où on
pensait en fait que on a même pas encore
démarré le projet
et il allait être
et un monsieur du nom de
vous a dit écoutez les gars en fait ce
que vous devez faire
vous avez besoin juste d'une boxe que
vous devez faire si vous trouvez une
banque un peu plus petite qui n'est pas
sur le marché bien public et vous
arrivez à faire comprendre à cette
banque
qui en fait ce que vous voulez faire
c'est étendre le marché
bingo c'est ça la solution en fait
et ils nous obtiendrons avec une banque
et ont reçu à convaincre la banque et on
a fait une brèche dans l'écosystème
et on se rend vite compte en fait que
on doit avoir les deux pieds 1 dans
l'océan rouge
et un dans le sillon bleu il reste
et on se rend vite compte en fait que à
force de parler aux gens de l'océan
rouge on devient comme eux et on doit
fonctionner comme eux
et très vite on se dit non c'est pas
possible ce qu'on va faire nous
on va absorber la complexité de nos
séances
et on va servir la magie à nos clients
si la banque demande à ce que le client
se déplace pour aller récupérer sa carte
nous on va pas faire comme ça on va dire
au client prends ton téléphone ouvre
l'application commande la carte à 9h à
midi on te livre la carte
[Applaudissements]
et c'est ce qu'on a fait
et vous savez quoi les clients nous ont
suivi ils étaient merveilleux
de la stratégie absorbe la complexité
de la magie avec nous et je pense qu'on
avait trouvé le bon chemin
le client
il est content on va arriver à se
développer
et on a fait de la satisfaction client
notre obsession on était obsédé par le
client
moi je parcourrai les forums Facebook à
la recherche du Commentaire négatifs et
quand je vois un commentaire négatif
j'appelle la personne bonjour monsieur
je suis président
m'explique ok je repars au four on
corrige ça on a fait ça on a fait ça
semaine après semaine à la sortie de
nouvelle version de l'application
et c'est comme ça qu'on a senti le
paiement c'est comme ça qu'on a sorti la
carte virtuelle c'est comme ça qu'on a
sorti le transferts
bancaire c'est comme ça qu'on a sorti
les IBAN pour recevoir le salaire
et à la fin qu'est-ce qui se passe le
client se sent aimé
et le client vous le donne
majorité se propage crash grâce à don au
bouche à oreille
c'est tellement bon que vous en parlez
autour de vous
et le danger avec tout ça soit c'est que
à force de vouloir rendre la vie du
client radio
on pense souvent
qu'il faut prendre raccourci
mais la réalité est que comme j'ai pas
envie de crier c'est aussi en bleu
la personne qui régule le cerveau
regarde de près et à la moindre faute
ils vont vous faire
et donc on a un niveau d'exigence
terme de régulation supérieure souvent
aux banques parce que on n'a pas droit à
la faute et c'est ça la difficulté
l'exercice continuer de respecter les
règles de différents rouges et servir la
magie aux clients dans les séances de
tout cela c'est un coup
et on s'est rendu vite quand on fait que
on allait manquer d'argent
le projet encore une fois allait être
où trouver les fonds pour financer cette
entreprise
dans le monde est start-up il y a un
concept qu'on appelle le capitalisme
les investisseurs et donc on a commencé
à faire des revenus avec ses
investisseurs et c'était toujours la
même en gaine est-ce que vous avez de
créer la tienne nouveau ça n'a aucun
sens en plus vous êtes dans un pays
francophones nous on aime les Nigéria on
aime le Kenya la Côte d'Ivoire
parce que nous dites
et c'est comme une bombe à retardement
parce que ce passage
et donc on a regardé on s'est dit OK
on va tenter impossible
si on arrive à intégrer le meilleur
accélérateur du start-up au monde tous
ces gars qui nous disent non ils vont
nous dire
et donc on projet de postuler à why
combinator qui est le meilleur
accélérateur de startup au monde en
silicone
qui consultent au programme chaque année
et ils n'ont pas que 300 400 c'est plus
difficile de rentrer là-bas que demain
après
on se dit que si on y arrive ça va
changer les choses et donc pendant des
semaines on regarde des dizaines
d'heures de vidéos YouTube comment
poursuivre
et on postule
on passe le premier tour même en ligne
et on arrive à l'entretien
et l'entretien c'est quoi c'est 10
minutes pendant lequel 3 partenaires
associés vous parlent vous pose des
questions donc imaginez un business
model établi que vous devez expliquer en
10 minutes
commencez en anglais comment c'est
difficile et imaginer
un business de l'océan bleu qui n'a qui
est nouveau qui est sur un marché
inconnu pour eux comment c'est difficile
à expliquer et confinement je me dis non
c'est mort on a pas eu
est-ce que les gens de vos pays sont
intéressés par la solution vous avez un
mois pour vous prouver que
je suis intéressé par la solution
je me rappelle pas avoir aussi peu dormi
une période de ma vie
qu'est-ce qu'on fait moi je pars pour
les supermarché je vais à GO Sport je
vais à cette histoire je veux partout
dans les entreprises je donne la carte à
qui peut je dis à tous mes amis prenez
la carte et tout ça et en un mois il a
une traction formidable il nous rappelle
ils disent c'est bon vous êtes à
l'intérieur
une fois qu'on est rentrés communautaire
nous sommes partis d'un point A ou les
gens disaient on va vous donner votre
argent un point B ou c'est à notre tour
et on lui a dit mettez-vous
votre argent
[Musique]
et
ça a changé les choses pour nous
une fois ça j'ai pris cette photo un
matin quand je suis arrivé au bureau à 6
heures
en fait on avait tellement cravacher
à quel point
accompli de mes choses
d'amour affranchi là-bas des 1,5
millions de téléchargement en Côte
d'Ivoire
la barre des 200 milliards de fonds de
transaction générée sur la plateforme
et tout ça pas une équipe de 150
collaborateurs 25 ans moyen d'âge 51% de
femmes
[Applaudissements]
non c'est pas ça
dans mon compte j'ai contribué à créer
cela en seulement 3 ans
et puis tu es parti de ma frustration
moi je crois
la prochaine fois que vous serez
dans une situation de frustration
rappelez-vous que vous pouvez utiliser
cette frustration comme carburant vous
pouvez utiliser cette frustration comme
passion
et moi je crois en la jeunesse africaine
pourquoi parce que depuis notre
naissance le système est contre nous en
fait parce que rien autour de nous ne
marche rien il y a rien qui marche
autour de nous et ça
mais je crois aussi que ça nous forge ça
nous donne les qualités ça nous donne la
résilience ça nous donne l'ingéniosité
la créativité pour faire face aux
difficultés je crois que ça nous forge
ou aller justement créer cette océan
bleu donc à chaque carrefour
à chaque carrefour vous allez voir un
problème
derrière ce problème et sûrement une
situation un système qui refuse de
changer
mais vous avez les qualités
ou changer les choses tout ce que tout
ce dont vous avez besoin c'est de
merci
[Applaudissements]